all right i want to turn now to some
breaking news in new york democrats have
just passed a massive restrictions on
concealed carry in the wake of the
supreme court's decision to expand gun
rights and allow the second amendment to
exist in places like new york after
passing both chambers in a special
session today governor holcol signed
into law moments ago a measure banning
concealed carry pretty much everywhere
listen to this list
we are creating a definitive list of
sensitive locations where individuals
will not be able to carry firearms
restaurants bars public transportation
subway buses and in times square
all right that's just to start now that
list went on and on and on this
effectively neuters
concealed carry in a city where crime is
rampant and now in order to get a permit
to carry in the few places that are left
you better be ready to fork over your
social media history let's see if a
lawsuit ensues potential firearm owners
will be asked to divulge all social
media accounts maintained over the past
three years as well as provide
references to testing to their good
moral character my next guest will get
plenty of those references he is the
republican nominee to the
the governor's race in new york city he
is going to be taking on governor holcol
congressman lee zeldin welcome what is
your take on the new gun laws in
response to the
supreme court decision in new york
i think it's terrible and here we are
going into independence day weekend and
this is the gift to law abiding new
yorkers i think that we need to separate
a law-abiding new yorker who wants to
safely and securely carry a firearm for
solely their self-defense and the
criminals who want to carry
firearms illegally and commit offense
after offense after offense harming
others and then because of the system in
new york they keep ending up back on the
streets now what they're doing with this
action today up in albany is targeting
the law-abiding new yorker i don't think
they're making new york more safe
they're making new york less safe
they're creating these locations as
targets
because now as a criminal if you wanted
to carry out one of your acts of
targeting someone with an illegal
firearm you know that you're likely to
encounter less resistance because the
only people who care about these laws
pass today are the law-abiding citizens
so
for people just to know put in layman's
terms the supreme court looked at this
and said the second amendment's really
been taken away from places like new
york it really concerns six other cities
you can have a concealed carry permit if
to but in a two-page insert
justice kavanaugh came out and said
listen
name some places to restrict
to bring guns by courthouses like
schools like times square and then just
name it but they've simply gone over the
top don't you think this invites another
lawsuit
yeah exactly it's almost as if they saw
what the supreme court did and then they
wanted to go even further than they went
earlier in a way
they just went even worse than what the
supreme court just said was
unconstitutional so now they are
inviting another lawsuit and now you're
wasting the judicial system's time
because it's gonna have to go through
that entire process and the supreme
court is gonna have to decide again and
it's showing a lack of respect for the
rule of law and the lack of respect for
the constitution
35 million dollars 35 million dollars
will be set aside to make sure new york
is a welcome place for abortions that
was also put forward by the governor
today as she brought that up talking
about different places to provide
abortions for states that might be
banning it for the most part what's your
reaction we need 35 million to have more
abortions
no the reason why governor holcol is
pushing this is because she doesn't want
to talk about the issues that matter
most to new yorkers the state is going
the wrong direction she doesn't want to
talk about crime and public safety she
doesn't want to talk about people
struggling to afford to survive in new
york whether it's getting your own home
or it's the cost of gas and just the
overall cost of living so she's trying
to find some other way to activate her
base because they don't really like her
new yorkers have not had a very good
first impression of governor hulkel
there's a lack of excitement enthusiasm
they don't think that she's doing a good
job so she's trying to
put fear into people on the issue of
abortion right and try to divide people
and i think this is this isn't about
being pro-life versus pro-choice she's
going to the extent that this is
pro-abortion she's trying to go on a
national scene to be the chief promoter
of it as if it's a great thing that more
and more people should consider getting
congressman i want to hear i did want to
hear your this suggestion that you just
made uh today about where abortions
could be taking place tell me if you can
get behind this
mr president we'd ask that you consider
your ability to use federal facilities
what am i talking about
veterans hospitals military bases and
other places where the federal
government controls the jurisdiction in
some of the states that are hostile to
women's rights and make sure that those
services can be available to other women
military bases is that a good move
no absolutely not and it's really uh
it's sad that this is somebody who
really at this point desperate to get a
four-year term as governor this november
is trying to get this creative you have
this opportunity the president of the
united states is sitting there in front
of you you can advocate for whatever you
want to advocate for
and you're you're not advocating for
anything
that is why new york leads the entire
country in population loss
you have these forums
and and you could be making asks for
help for resources for leadership for
competency
and you're putting all of that aside you
know just a grandstand and try to again
activate your base and instill fear upon
them
lee won the nomination a lot of people
say you have the best shot of a
republican since george pataki actually
won and beat mario cuomo
what is it going to take for you to beat
uh lieutenant governor now governor
hocle
we're all in for the next four months
we're going to be campaigning our tales
off all across this state it's not just
about republicans and conservatives but
independents democrats they're
disenfranchised democrats if you are
concerned about rising energy costs well
then let's reverse the ban on a safe
extraction of natural gas one party
democratic rule wants to ban all gas
hookups on new construction statewide
let's repeal cashless bail she says we
need more data oh by the way when people
were asking her the question yesterday
about this new legislation she's passing
she said she doesn't need any data in
order to act i say let's fire alvin
bragg he's refusing to enforce the law
kathy hokel says he just got there cut
him some slack he's doing his job
so the contrast is stark we need to
bring that message to new yorkers of all
stripes in all counties in new york and
win this race to save new york he's a
four-time congressman uh he does know
new york he's represented a very purple
district in suffolk county for four
different terms lee zeldin best of luck
thank you brian hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else